I may look like a nice English lady in a
sensible cards again but these days it's
a thin veneer and it started to crack
who wants to bring kids into this bloody
world my point is I just don't think
that the world needs more cave talk her
crawl
one of the most unsung figures of
alternative rock hasn't been seen in 20
years that's him
wow so gorgeous thank you I think I've
had enough Tucker bloody crows lost 20
lifetimes Tucker has a new album and I
don't want to spend my time with someone
who doesn't get it well somebody knew
Juliette naked is the naked attempt to
squeeze a few more quid out of a
long-dead career you wrote this is the
strangest thing I met someone on the
Internet you're finally entering the
modern age event that review I posted
you nailed it I couldn't have explained
it better myself Tucker cross Taku CRO
as in Duncan's idle talk at work yeah
it's me Lee me what's your story ditto
it's really odd to be saying all this to
a stranger but life of a hunch I've
wasted the last 15 years of my life I
don't imagine this as much of a
consolation but I'm ashamed to say that
two decades have slipped through my
fingers at least you have a pass to live
up to big news I am coming to London
would you like to meet for a drink
we'd not sad well you find Yuki
beautiful spot
are you that's me in my high school
chess club so I can explain this I'm not
trying to talk Oh cut the head off
right have you been Duncan Thompson
stuck a crow I'm Stevie Wonder
real mature honey
you are you're drinking alcohol glass or
I'm not getting a famous American rock
star a glass of wolves I'm not that
famous okay Han I'm an alcoholic
well you'll fit right in it's wondering
if you'd be interested in me do you
think there's any way back for me you
sure this doesn't have something to do
with your idol coming along and fencing
me please how do we know that's even him
well I have Passport well that would be
super but all of this seems to be in
order
really oh thank god
[Music]
you